that is why it is so important to live
every day as if it were going to be our
last which is why I say that yesterday
doesn't matter Todd and Julie Chrisley
are making every moment count in the
days leading up to their prison
sentencing after being convicted of tax
fraud today is what we have and tomorrow
belongs to God because we're not
promised tomorrow you know I pray to God
every day last week the couple was
sentenced to a combined 19 years in
prison but prior to learning their fate
they recorded an episode of their
Chrisley confessions podcast the two
clearly leaning heavily on their faith
were all children of God God chose us
first whether we choose him or not we're
still his child but now in this storm
that we're in I feel like that I'm
closer to God than I've ever been but I
find myself screaming out because you
know in the Bible it says to scream out
to God to cry out to God you've heard me
say God please I'm I'm crying out to you
I don't know what else to do as a result
Todd and Julie are living every day like
it's their last there was something else
I heard this week that I thought was
powerful and it was actually by
Priscilla shires who I love that says
age is just a number and since we don't
know our death date we have to live
every day as if it's our last that is
why it is so important to live every day
as if it were going to be our last which
is why I say that yesterday doesn't
matter today is what we have and
tomorrow belongs to God because we're
not promised tomorrow because of all of
this our faith has intensified
tremendously
and I believe that it that I don't
believe that I believe that everything
that happens
God already knows it's going to happen
and God he knows how you're going to get
through it so what's next for the
Chrisleys well Todd is expected to serve
a 12-year sentence and Julie seven plus
they'll both serve 16 months probation
there is no dispute that during both the
trial and the sentencing the government
used significant evidence that they
called from the Chrisley's reality TV
show from their media appearances so in
that sense the fact of their being on
reality television can in oftentimes be
helpful to the government not only in
determining that they want to initiate a
prosecution but in moving forward with
that prosecution as for what it means
for the future of their reality shows
E.T has learned it is unlikely Chrisley
Knows Best will continue just because
you knew it was coming doesn't make it
any less hard oh great put a source
close to the family says that the USA
Network has some episodes of season 10
that were shot prior to the trial it's
expected they will Air next year
[Music]